when I started working on this problem
or I guess when when it started working
on me was probably really in the mid 80s
and I found myself suffering from two
things one was a very lengthy sequence
of nightmares about nuclear destruction
and they're very affecting dreams and
associated with that was a sense of
amazement that a dream that was that
awful could reflect a reality that could
be that awful and an additional
amazement out the fact that despite the
production of thousands and tens and
thousands of weapons of unimaginable
destruction and that qualitative
qualitative change in human capacity
that represented that people could go
about their day-to-day lives without
acting as if anything fundamental
whatsoever had changed now I've never
really been able to figure out why that
disturbed me so much when it seemed to
not disturb to any profound degree most
of the people I knew it doesn't really
matter the upshot of it was of it was
that I spent I probably spent my whole
life trying to understand what evil was
and more importantly what might be done
about it
it's a strange pursuit in some ways for
an academic done undertake because
academics tend to talk about academic
things and one thing you can say about
evil is that whatever it is it's not
bloody well academic it's not an
intellectual issue it's an existential
issue and it's it's not a theoretical
issue it's an it's an issue that deals
with that absolute nature of reality and
I guess sometimes I think that people
who go into academia go into academia
shield themselves from having to ask
questions about the absolute nature of
reality so anyways I think before you
can talk about something before you can
dare to talk about something like evil
you should do some thinking about what
it is that you're talking about
definitionally speaking I learned this I
believe from a historian named Jeffrey
Burton Russell who wrote a very detailed
history of the idea of the devil in the
1980s when such histories were were
strange to say the least he he was very
interested in the history of the
embodiment of ideas of evil and one of
the things he his work did for me was to
help me clarify the distinction between
two terrible things the distinction
distinction that has to be made and
that's the distinction between tragedy
and evil and I don't think you can talk
about it evil at all until you
distinguish it from tragedy and so I'm
going to try to distinguish evil from
tragedy by making some reference to the
essential existential condition of human
beings I would say that the nature of
human being is such that it consists of
a confrontation with the bounded finite
with the unbounded infinite and that
those are the bare facts of the matter
and the facts are that the the world of
experience as it presents itself to us
is literally and not metaphorically
complex beyond our capacity to
understand and that means that people
deal in a real sense on an ongoing basis
with the infinite and I believe that
that fact is the reason why religious
experience is essentially and belief is
essentially endemic to mankind it's a
human universal and it's not because
people believe it's because human
existence as such consists of a
confrontation between the finite and the
infinite and religious systems merely
take that into account
now our finitude in the face of the
infinite has some inevitable
consequences and I would say those
consequences are essentially the
existential conditions of life the first
of those consequences is is that the
finite is always overwhelmed by the
infinite it has to be because it can't
encapsulate it and so what that meant
means is that it's that suffering is
central to the nature of human existence
and suffering exists as a consequence of
the consequences of our limitations I
mean every single person who's alive is
going to die
and every single person who's alive is
going to deal with with serious physical
illness and mental distress if they
don't suffer if they aren't suffering it
directly immediately right now on their
own
it's almost inevitably the case that
every single person who walks the earth
is confronting that the bare bones of
reality at that level in the guise of an
afflicted family member and so the fact
of our finitude is is again no academic
issue it's essential to the nature of
our being and we're forced to deal with
it on an ongoing basis so I would say
insufficiency is built into human
experience and and there are existential
consequences to that now I read
something a long time ago and I don't
remember who wrote it but it was written
about Jewish commentary on the Torah God
is omniscient omnipotent and omnipresent
what does he lack and answers'
limitation and that's that's a that's a
riddle and an answer of unparalleled
brilliance as far as I'm concerned
because I think it speaks deeply to
something about the central nature of
existence itself and that is that
without limitation there's no being now
that's a hard thing to understand but I
think you can understand it in a number
of different ways the first thing you
might want to understand is that I play
this game with my students sometimes in
my class I'll come up to a student a
pigment poor victim at random and come
up to them say okay we're to play a game
say and they say ok and I say well you
move first well they don't know what to
do and the reason for that is because
the limiting parameters of the game have
not been defined and as a consequence of
that they're stunned by their infinite
freedom into complete immobility and
what that means in a sense is that the
in the absence of serious constraint
there can be no choice no freedom no
existence and I believe this to be
fundamentally true just as the fact that
human being is vulnerable is
fundamentally true here's another
example that I think is more it's more
personal to me and it emerged in my
imagination as a consequence of my
contemplation of my son's vulnerability
so I have children there are teenagers
now I still like them
one of my one of the things I was really
struck by when my children were little
was how perfect they were like and I
believe that that was the benevolence of
God in a sense children are tremendously
difficult they're a tremendous
responsibility but they're so perfect
and they manifest that perfection in
such a remarkable way that that's the
payment for taking on the responsibility
of bringing them into the be into being
and caring for them and the thing about
being a parent is that the vulnerability
of people is made manifest to you in a
way that was never the case prior to
that and it's not it's haunting and it's
beautiful but it's also exactly right in
a way and I was thinking well look at my
son he's a little kid you know you got
to chase after him all the time you can
get sick people hurt him you know people
are going to be mean to him he's going
to be disappointed in his life he's
vulnerable and it's it's it's a constant
tragic reality that he's vulnerable I
thought well okay let's say we want to
do something about that so let's say we
make him so that no one can pick on him
so it could inflate him to about 20 feet
high and equip him with a metallic
skeleton and an ax and a cast-iron
exoskeleton and you could equip him with
a computerized intelligence that far
supersedes his own and you could remove
his vulnerabilities one by one
hypothetically and of course more and
more we're in a position where we could
do that reality and one of the things I
realized right away was that as you
remove the vulnerabilities you remove
the thing you love and then I started to
understand more deeply that
vulnerability was a precondition for
human being and that was a desirable
precondition because the thing is about
human existence that are wonderful and
remarkable are so integrally tied up
with vulnerability that they're actually
inextricable the Jewish commentary what
the infinite lacks is the finite there's
a more abstract way of getting at the
same thing if you could do absolutely
anything you wanted at any point and be
anywhere you wanted and be anything you
wanted and if there was nothing that was
out of your reach there would be nothing
to do because you'd be everything at
once and when you're everything at once
which is at least in principle the
position of God
there's no story and there's no being
and there's something about being that
is a story and without limitation
there's no story so then the question
starts to become with regards to
consideration of human vulnerability is
there a way to conduct your life in such
a manner that the intrinsic
vulnerability that characterizes your
life is rendered not only acceptable but
desirable and to me that's the central
question of existence and I tell you get
that wrong you're on the wrong track and
if you're on the wrong track man you are
in one terrible place I would say with
regards to tragedy right humans are
vulnerable and that's tragic
but if tragedy is the price that we pay
for existence then so be it
if existence is justifiable and so
tragedy itself which is merely a
revelation of our vulnerability can't be
regarded as evil it's just a it's a
condition of existence and so it's
necessary to distinguish the tragic
conditions of existence from evil before
you can even address the problem and I
think what that means to some degree is
you should not blame on the relationship
between the finite and the infinite the
terrible failings of humanity that can
be laid directly at the feet of human
beings so earthquakes aren't evil and
cancer isn't evil and mental illness
isn't evil and predators aren't evil
they're they just are part of the way
things are but there are certain
categories of human action that are
definitely outside the parameters of
mere tragedy and those are the things we
really have to get a handle on evil for
me is differentiated from tragedy by its
lack of necessity and it's volunteerism
and it's a tenant I think of modern
materialistic thought that there are
social or material causes for actions
and it's an extraordinarily useful
theory and I think but I think one of
the unfortunate consequences of that is
that we've tended to write off much of
human misbehavior and attribute it to
say insufficiencies and material
conditions which is not an it's not an
acceptable theory there are all sorts of
human cultures that were characterized
by virtually complete absence of
material
luxury well-being whose cultures were
highly functional and and highly moral
and to describe the propensity towards
misbehavior as a consequence of economic
inequality is entirely beside the point
as far as I'm concerned evil is more
pernicious than that which is generated
for example by social inequality I think
it's actually although this is a
terrifying thought in some ways it's
more appropriate to consider it a form
of demonically warped aesthetic and I'll
give you a couple of examples of what I
mean by that for example because the
exact because the manifestation of this
warped pathetic aesthetic makes itself
apparent under certain conditions so for
example I think it made itself apparent
in the imagination of the first
politician who can to coined the acronym
mad or mutual assured destruction
that's an aesthetic of evil to make a
joke of a situation that catastrophic
indicates the kind of malevolence that
lurks behind the fact that such a
condition exists the motto on the gates
of Auschwitz I believe in the second
world war work will make you free
that's another manifestation of the
aesthetic of evil it's a terrible
terrible ironic joke and it's
instructive to meditate on what sort of
imagination would have the arrogance to
tell such a terrible joke the
concentration camps are classic examples
of evil and I think by analyzing at
least certain kinds of events that
occurred within them it's easier to get
a clear idea of what evil constitutes
and one of the stories that's always
haunted me I guess is I believe it's
another story derived from Auschwitz the
prison guards and our wits would take
the prisoners who were already stripped
of their dignity and to whatever degree
possible their identity and their
culture under language and their status
of valuable beings and yet that wasn't
sufficient they needed to be tortured in
addition to that before they
were killed and the torts are often
consisted of a self-evidently
counterproductive work a situation that
also frequently characterized activity
in the Soviet gulag archipelago where
perhaps 60 million people met their
death
a typical auswitch example was the
requirement for prisoners to carry
100-pound socks of wet salt from one
side of the compound and then back again
now that's evil as far as I'm concerned
and you have to think about from an
aesthetic perspective in a sense because
it's a celebration of horror and it's a
it's a conscious attempt to violate the
conditions that make life itself
tolerable and it's aimed at
dehumanization destruction of the ideal
and at an even deeper level revenge
against the conditions of existence
itself I've tried to understand the
developmental pathway that leads to acts
like that my academic research as well
as my clinical experience has revealed
to me that what appears to lie at the
bottom of motivation for the excesses of
behavior that characterize evil are too
tightly causally related factors one
arrogance another resentment and both of
those are tied up with vulnerability of
human beings in the face of the infinite
but but tied up with something more
profound as well the most thorough
account of this that I've managed I
think at least two partially comprehend
I believe is contained in the first
couple of the stories in the Old
Testament in Genesis the story of Adam
and Eve in the fall of man and the
immediately following story of Cain and
Abel as far as we can tell those are
very very old stories they predate
Judaism at least in some of their in
some of their structural elements it's
conceivable that some of the
and those stories are as old as the
human capacity to tell stories itself
assuming that they were grounded in an
oral tradition that predated the written
tradition and we know that oral
traditions can last at least in some
forms unchanged for periods of up to
25,000 years so the anthropological and
archaeological evidence is fairly clear
on that point these are very very very
old stories and people remember them and
created them for reasons we really don't
understand and they're they're strange
and mysterious and unforgettable all at
the same time the story of Adam and Eve
as far as I can tell is the story of the
coming of consciousness the coming of
self-consciousness to mankind and I
think that the human that the human
human self-consciousness is what
separates us from animals in Genesis
there's an insistence that when Adam ate
the Apple that Eve offered to him the
scales fell from his eyes and the first
thing that he realized was that he was
naked and what that seems to me to mean
is that I mean I think it means first of
all that women make men self-conscious
and I think there's ample reason to
presume not and there's good
evolutionary reasons for suggesting why
that might be the case because sexual
selection among human beings has been a
primary force of evolutionary
development and sexual selection and
human beings is primarily conducted by
women so for example as Roy has pointed
out in his address to the APA a few
years ago and I hope I get this right
twice as many of your relatives who are
women ISM as men and that means that
women are more frequently reproductive
ly successful than men and that they
reject most men and the rejection of a
man for reproductive purposes by a woman
is the most serious form of rejection
that's possible from an evolutionary
point of view because the judgment is
that well you might be nice enough to
talk to but you're sure not fit to have
your genes propagate into the next
generation so it's no wonder that women
can make self make men self-conscious
and I think there's some reason to
presume that it's the sexual selection
forces that women placed upon man that
drove rapid human cortical evolution and
the development of self-consciousness
now that's a leap and there's
way I can justify that in the course of
this particular talk but I think there
is good reason to presume that it's the
case in Genesis human beings become self
conscious and the first thing that
happens to them is that they realize
they're naked and then the next thing
that happens to them is they develop the
moral sense to tell the difference
between good and evil and it's a very
strange thing because in some sense
before our creature is self conscious
there is no distinction between good and
evil because as I said before a predator
is not evil it's just a predator the
fact of a predator like a wolf might be
a tragedy for the rabbit but you can't
be assuming that the wolf is evil merely
because it wants to eat the rabbit but
with the dawning of self-consciousness
there seems to be the emergence of a
moral sense that's essentially unique to
human beings and that has something to
do with our capacity to reflect upon the
mechanisms of our action and then for
some reason to be able to modify those
actions and to choose which ones to
implement into the future in the future
we don't understand that and you can
even deny if you'd like that the the
phenomena of free choice exists but our
culture is essentially predicated on the
notion that it does exist and in the
absence of evidence that it doesn't I'm
going to take the easy way out and
assume that it does otherwise things
fall apart and they fall apart badly
when after Adam and Eve becomes self
conscious the first thing they do is
close themselves and to me that's a
mythological description of the
emergence of culture as an intersession
between the negative the fundamental
vulnerability and nakedness of the human
form and the depredations of nature if
you realize that you're vulnerable and
prone to death the first thing you're
going to do is to start rearranging the
manner in which you construe yourself so
that you can protect yourself from such
an unfortunate outcome that's I think
partly why God curses Adam with the
necessity of work once he finds out once
God finds out that people have become
self conscious like if you know that
what's that winter is lurking in the
future for example you're going to work
and animals don't work they're just
motivated to do whatever they do but
humans work and that means they subvert
their day to day motivations their
immediate motivations for the purposes
of future security and there's a real
cost to that I mean part of the cost is
separation from the pure and
unadulterated flow of
life and I believe that people suffer
from that absence of flow continually
and and and the advantage they gain from
it is that they can plan for the future
but the disadvantage is that they're
calculating and cold and separated from
their own instinctual resources Eve of
course is cursed by what's going to be
terrible pain in childbirth and that's
related to the development of the
immense skull size that characterizes
human infants and their incredibly
lengthy period of dependence which is
also associated with their immense print
after Adam and Eve become self-conscious
they hide and this is actually a comical
part of Genesis it's never really read
as a comedy but it is a comedy even the
fall itself is a comedy and so they're
hiding away behind a bush and God comes
walking through the garden and God the
infinite is accustomed to walking
without him with no interruption of the
flow of information between them
madam is narrowed God says you know
where where have you gone and Adam says
oh well I'm hiding and God says which is
kind of stupid really and this is why
it's a comments like he's hiding behind
a bush this is God and he can see
through bushes and like Adam should know
that it doesn't really matter he's
hiding me on this bush anyways and and
God so Adam says I'm hiding and and God
says well why well you know what why are
you hiding
lots cuz Adams ashamed and Adam says
well I'm naked and this is an example of
the tremendous compression of human
wisdom into a few lines that
characterizes mythology say well why
would people hide from God once they
realize they're naked and I would say
well that's pretty obviously once you
know you're vulnerable or do you really
have enough courage to manifest any sort
of semblance of a divine destiny well
answer that is pretty much clearly no
and it's no bloody wonder and so the
hiding is people hide when they're
self-conscious and vulnerable and where
they hide from me they hide from their
deepest destiny and it's no wonder God
says okay yeah well you figured that out
how that happened and Adam says and this
is karma hoodoo was the woman's fault
which i think is really funny and
which I actually may have been the
original sin and not the eating of the
apple right the first time that the man
blamed the woman for his self-conscious
misery I think that's the real fall and
not the rise of self-consciousness
itself
anyways we know the rest of the story
God says oh well the cats out of the bag
now you know you know you're vulnerable
and from here on in history starts your
own a paradise you're out of unconscious
identification with the natural world
you're going to work you're going to
sweat lots of the time it isn't going to
work and women they're going to be
beholden to their husbands not because
that's divine Fiat but because the
developmental the developmental
dependency of a human infant is so
extreme that women are cursed to rely on
men for protection when they're at their
most vulnerable fine so that
self-consciousness and an explanation
for why people would hide away from
their destiny but then the next story
the Cain and Abel story really
elaborates that out and describes it and
so Cain and Abel of course are two sons
of Adam and Eve and they're really the
first people because of course Adam and
Eve were made by God so they're really
not people at all because people are
born and Cain and Abel are the first two
people and they characterized as far as
I can tell to canonical patterns of
reaction to the terrible vulnerability
that's revealed as a consequence of the
development of self-consciousness Cain
and Abel make sacrifices to God why
human cultures make sacrifices that's
what they do
sacrifice sacrificial rituals a human
universal blood sacrifices a human
universal human sacrifice at least in
some anthropological epics was regarded
as a human Universal why do people make
sacrifices to God to please them seems
like a mystery of modern people I ask my
students what sacrifices did you make to
go to university well they can answer
that 2/10 of a second you know they
can't party as much as they might have
they can't drink nearly as much beer as
they might have liked to more seriously
a lot of them work a lot of them have
put their families in serious financial
straits to send them to university
they've given up all sorts of things
in order to pursue pursue a course of
action that they believe will best
ensure their harmonious relationship
with the nature of reality everyone
makes sacrifices ok we can say that now
because we're psychologically
sophisticated and linguistically
sophisticated we know something about
human psychology but thousands and
thousands of years ago before people had
this explicit psychological acumen the
best they could do is act out and tell
stories about human psychology because
they hadn't developed any further than
that and Cain and Abel is one of those
stories the sacrifices are burnt on an
altar why well a smoke rises well so
what well God's up in the sky and if the
smoke rises up there and he gets a whiff
of it he can tell what the quality of
the sacrifice was and you can laugh
about that and you can think it you can
think about it as primitive but it's not
permanent its artistic and it's
beautiful in it and it's accurate and
here's why is because before the
invention of the electrical light and
maybe before the invention of fire and
the closest to human being could ever
get to direct confrontation with the
absolute unknown was to look up at the
night sky because the night sky
especially when it's sprinkled with
stars confronts you directly with the
fact of the infinite and to make the
presupposition that God resides in the
infinite and and you're having a direct
experience of the infinite at that
moment is not a primitive notion it's a
it's a very intelligent and and creative
hypothesis and so the notion that God
occupies the sky the dazed guy being
equally as impressive as the night sky
is not a primitive hypothesis it's a
reflection of the nature of a certain
kind of human experience you burn
something and you send the smoke up God
gets a crack at determining the quality
of your offering the quality of your
sacrifice well let's get let's be
perfectly clear about this if your
sacrifices aren't first-rate the nature
of your relationship with the infinite
is going to suffer dreadfully and that's
exactly what the story of Cain and Abel
reveals now Abel he's a trusting
character he believes in the nature of
experience in the nature of existence
when he's called on to make a sacrifice
he sacrifices the best that he has to
offer and that makes God happy and as a
consequence everything that Abel touches
turns to gold everyone likes them they
respect them his crops multiply
he's successful with women plus he's a
wonderful guy so you could hardly
imagine a more annoying creature if you
possibly attempted to do it whereas Cain
C Cain has reacted to his
self-consciousness by withdrawing from
the infinite and there's a tremendous
danger in that because it starts to mean
that he relies purely on his own devious
devices to sale is shipped through the
shoals of life he believes as his
arrogance develops as a consequence of
his withdrawal from the infinite a
contact that he can't tolerate because
he can't tolerate his own vulnerability
that he is able to deceive the structure
of reality itself to offer second-rate
sacrifices to God himself who can see
absolutely everything because the
infinite is absolutely everything and to
prevail nonetheless well needless to say
this does not work and it doesn't work
in an obvious way if you talk to people
and they reveal to you their unnecessary
suffering it's very straightforward to
look behind what it is that they have to
say they'll tell you the poor decisions
they made in their lives and the
opportunities that they didn't take and
the chances that they didn't they didn't
have enough courage to grasp and the
sacrifices they fail to make there's
nothing mysterious about it and their
own experiences teach them full well
that they pathologized the relationship
they have with the nature of reality
well that's a terrible thing well in
Cain is dreadfully unhappy he's unhappy
because nothing he ever wants happens
and that's partly because he doesn't
really want it because if he really
wanted he'd make the right sacrifices
the salt is rubbed into his wounds by
the existence of his brother for whom
everything seems simple but of course
really isn't Cain goes to complain to
God and I had to read three or four
different translations of these
particular verses to figure out what
this meant then he says what in the
world is going on here
I'm marking myself to the bone I'm
sacrificing things left right and center
everything I touch turns to dirt
everything turns against me like what's
up with the nature of reality Cain's
essential vulnerability is revealed and
exacerbated by his pathological attitude
towards his own actions God says to him
insulae sin is a predatory cat that
crouches at your doorway and leaps on
you ad will it but if you only wanted to
you could master it and that is
absolutely the last thing that Cain
wants to hear because if things are
going from bad to worse for you and
you're playing a causal role in it
there's nothing more horrible than
something that someone can do you but
reveal to you in a way that you can't
deny that you're entirely complicit in
your own demise and that's exactly what
God does to Cain and so what is Cain do
well the logical thing would be listen
because if the structure of reality
itself tells you something it's best to
listen since there's no way out of it
but that's not what Cain does he's so
incensed by his scent essential
vulnerability compromised and
exacerbated by his failure to make the
appropriate sacrifices and to conduct
himself appropriately that he decides
then in their number one to destroy his
ideal to reduce the tension that he
feels when that ideal exists as a
contrast point and number two to destroy
the favorite son of God and so he goes
out into the field and kills Abel and
God comes along and says where's my
favorite son and Cain says I killed him
and it's so interesting to me that that
story is placed really it's the third
story in the Old Testament it's it's
with the archaic stories and it's a
story that reveals as far as I can tell
that there are two essential patterns of
reaction to the self-conscious
vulnerable conditions of existence and
one is humble approach to infinity with
determined attempts to make the
appropriate sacrifices the other is
arrogance resentment the keeping of
everything good for oneself and the
degeneration of the soul into something
that's homicidally murderous well the
story doesn't stop there and it gets
really compressed in this part and
that's perhaps because some of its being
lost with the passages of time but the
next thing that happens is that well God
doesn't punish Cain and you think that's
kind of strange
I mean Old Testament God he's punishing
people left right and center it's right
why not Cain and you think well he marks
Cain and he says to the people
who
around that they should leave him alone
because he's been marked by God as to be
left alone and the reason for that I
think and this is something that's
reflected on our legal system is that
murder promotes revenge and revenge
destroys societies and so God puts an
end to the situation right there and
then by telling people that despite the
fact that Cain has has committed a
terrible crime that there will be no
retribution Cain goes off and gets
married and he has a number of
generations of offspring if you insult a
member of the first generation of Cain's
offspring he doesn't kill you it kills
seven of you and if you insult a member
of the second generation of Cain's
offspring he doesn't kill seven of you
he kills seven times seven of you and
then on down the rape down the road of
the offspring of Cain is tubal Cain and
tubal Cain is the artificer of weapons
of war and this stunningly brilliant
story says in it's incredibly compressed
fashion that the motivation that drives
the commission of the worst human
atrocities is an inevitable social
consequence of the refusal of the
self-conscious individual to make the
sacrifices appropriate to establishing a
harmonious life and their consequent
degeneration into a kind of murderous
and resentment filled raged rage
propagating endlessly through its
variations in society until everything
comes to an end and the next story is
the flood and it's not surprising
because if things go from bad to worse
long enough everything falls and it's a
terrifying story and I didn't understand
that story I didn't understand that
story for years it wasn't really until I
read Alexander Solzhenitsyn that that I
developed
I think the cognitive capacity them to
even understand what the story meant
because Solzhenitsyn said it is Nobel
Prize accepting speech a single
new stop flying can bring down a tyranny
which is a stunning thing to say but I
would also say something that's been
amply demonstrated in the 20th century
because we have we have historical
examples of people who did precisely
that Gandhi did it facto Havel did it
Nelson Mandela did it Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag Archipelago was definitely one of
the acts blows that brought down the
Soviet Union a stunning achievement for
a person who started writing that book
by memorizing it when he was a
concentration camp victim this far away
from starvation it shows you as clearly
as anything possibly can
how powerful the human spirit can be if
it's willing to take on the obligation
of its relationship with the divine and
also how terrible things can become if
the responsibility of that burden is not
shouldered now it's no wonder as far as
I can tell that people don't think this
way because thinking this way is it's
catastrophic in a way because the burden
it places on the individual is so
extreme that it's almost unbearable
while in a but but that's exactly why it
is in Genesis to begin with that Adam
hides but he becomes conscious of his
own vulnerability it's like he thinks
well a creature such as I I could never
bear such a burden well there's a lot
more to people than meets the eye and
the only way I learned that was by
looking at people and my own peoples in
my own capacity for evil because I
started to realize that we regard
ourselves as narrow little beings in a
particular kind of box and there's real
comfort in that although there's
tremendous limitation you cannot see
your way out of that box until you know
well what I teach my students I teach
them about Nazi Germany and I try to
make them understand that there's an
overwhelming probability if they were in
Nazi Germany in the 1930s that they
would have been perpetrators and Nazis
and overwhelming probability and if they
can't accept that because it's a
historical fact they have absolutely no
idea who they are now imagining yourself
as a Nazi perpetrator is an unbearably
terrifying thing to do but I don't
believe that you can do I don't think
that you have any insight whatsoever
into your capacity for good until you
have some well-developed insight into
your capacity for evil because people
can tell you till they're blue in the
face about your capacity for good it
just sounds like ah it sounds like
wishful thinking it sounds like the sort
of thing that an advertiser might tell
you on TV it's just too good to be true
and I don't think people believe it but
I think that if you tell people that you
know in the cold dark corners of their
mind there are motivations that are so
terrible that they would they would
traumatize themselves if they were ever
revealed that everyone knows at some
level of analysis that that's absolutely
true
you think there's evidence throughout
history that it's possible for people to
be enlightened and you'd think since
enlightenment is viewed as the
medication for vulnerability and death
that everybody would be struggling as
hard as they possibly could to be
enlightened if such a state exactly and
precisely exists but if the barrier to
enlightenment is the development of self
consciousness of the individual humans
infinite capacity for evil then you can
be immediately convinced about why
enlightenment is in such short supply
when I finished my first provisional
examination of the sorts of motivations
that drove people to set up
concentration camps and to torture
people terribly in those camps I came to
a terrible conclusion it was a
conclusion that I think in some ways was
the worst thing that had ever happened
to me maybe intellectually and morally I
thought I came to understand why it is
that people dependent on their group
identity in their cultural
identification because that helped
protect themselves from their own
vulnerability you have to believe things
because you just don't know everything
so you have to believe things they fill
in the gaps the beliefs fill in the gaps
if the beliefs are stripped from you
then your defenses against the infinite
are stripped and it's no wonder that
people will defend their beliefs I
thought well you do if you're too
involved in defending your beliefs
you're going to be willing to kill other
people in their defence and we're so
technologically powerful now that we can
no longer be willing to kill other
people in the defense of our own beliefs
because the time for that is passed and
I realized well with you if you don't
stand up for your beliefs you leave
yourself bereft you're open to the
depredations of the infinite that's
equally intolerable it seems to leave no
way out there is a way out you know and
I think it's the way out that genuinely
religious people have tried to
offer humanity for thousands and
thousands of years and the way out of
the conundrum posed to you by your
reliance on ideological beliefs and your
vulnerability in the face of the unknown
is the development of a truly integrated
and powerful character and that's a
individual development and it means
constant confrontation with things you
don't understand and constant attempts
to ensure that your character is
composed of truth and solidity rather
than deceit and to make of yourself
something that's built on a rock and not
predicated on sand and the thing is it's
one thing to tell people that because
maybe they should take care of
themselves but I don't know if that's
enough to tell people because they don't
take care of themselves that well but
it's a completely other thing to say
look you know every time you make a
pathological moral decision you move the
one the world one step closer to
complete annihilation and I absolutely
believe that I think the historical
evidence is crystal clear and I also
think that every time you make an
appropriate moral decision and you
manifest moral courage in the face of
your own vulnerability then you move the
world one step farther from the break
and every that's the case for every
single person you know Solzhenitsyn said
drawing on his Eastern Orthodox
Christian background every single person
is the center of the world a center of
the world not the center of the world
the world is a complicated place it can
have all sorts of centers it's hard to
believe that you might be one of them
but everything about human existence is
hard to believe the fact that it's here
at all is hard to believe the nature of
it's hard to believe everything that
human beings does is so ridiculous and
remarkable that it's like it's a
consistently and constantly unfolding
miracle the idea that each of you might
be a center of the cosmos in that
infinite admixture of ridiculousness and
absurdities is hardly more than one more
ridiculous thing to swallow all
summarize I guess said the tragedy is a
precondition for being being is the
interplay between the finite and the
infinite and in that interplay there's
tragedy and there's no way out of that
evil something different
evils the conscious attempt to make the
conditions of existence more
pathological than they have to be and
it's motivated by conscious intent the
motivations arise because people pay a
terrible price for their self conscious
awareness and that awareness is their
awareness of their vulnerability and
that is a terrible thing to be aware of
that vulnerability can be confronted
forthrightly accepted and the
appropriate decisions made alternatively
people can retreat into their own
rationalistic arrogance and attempt to
deceive themselves and everyone else
about the nature of their own existence
and about the nature of reality that
pathway leads to nothing but destruction
I think that there's good reason to
assume that it's too late in the
developmental course as a species for
that path to be acceptable anymore
because we're too powerful and if too
many people stay on that path we're
going to do ourselves in and so I would
say as we've become more technologically
powerful an increasing moral burden is
being placed on each of us it matters to
the to the to the destiny of the cosmos
whether or not you get your Morlock
straight and I don't mean that in a
trivial way I believe that that's as
close to an empirical fact as anything
that can be demonstrated I also believe
that's as terrifying a thing to consider
as anything you could possibly imagine
and maybe it's too much to ask of people
but you know our great religious
traditions do continually remind us that
inside every human being there's a spark
of divinity and that idea is a
precondition for our entire system of
law there's always the possibility that
it's true and if it's true it means that
there is a there's a there's an infinite
avenue of potential that lays open to
every single person and that the ability
to transform the terrible conditions of
reality into something not only
acceptable but worthy of celebration
actually lies within our grasp an
alternative that the alternative to that
is the continual generation of a kind of
hell that's so incomprehensibly awful
that by any reasonable person standards
it has to be regarded as something to
avoid that's all I have to say about
that